[音楽]
これは
俺の3人です
今日は僕が
俺の三輪にたどり着くまでのことをお話します
これがなんだかわかりますか
みりんの原料である持ち米米麹
そして焼酎
このたった3つの原料じっくりと熟成させるだけでみりんになるんです
600年前室町時代には既に作られていたと記録に残っています
ここ
碧南市では
江戸時代
全国にたくさん船で運んでいました
山も海もあり
温暖な気候なので
きっと工事が喜ぶところだったんですね
またここ三河地方では
醤油味噌
素酒
みりんなど8校職員が
沢山
作られているところです
全国的にも醸造がとても盛んなところです
その中で碧南市は
みりんの産地で打つ
現在でも5件ミーティング等が残っています
僕のおじいさんです
僕が三代目になります
100年前おじいさんは
20代で商売を始めました
でも
40代半ばにして
お酒の飲みすぎでこの世を去りました
僕の酒好きはきっとおじいさんのせいです
父親が45歳僕はもちろんあったこともありません
おじいさんの死後
おばあさんが地町 a 棟
みりんづくりを引き継ぎ
大量生産の時代に入ります
みりんの作り方には2通りあります
一つは
昔ながら
手作りで
じっくりと時間をかけ
もち米
米コージー焼酎だけで作る
味の濃い3
もう一つは
工場の中で時間をかけず
持ち米米麹醸造用アルコールと盗塁を添加した味の薄いみりん
シチューやの作る3人は
大量に早く作る
いかに安く作るかがカギでした
誰が作った母
売る人も買う人も
全く気にしない
それでいても
作れば作るだけ売れる時代でした
自分の作ったみりんを説明すらできない
仕事に誇りを持たない
そんな父親が大嫌いで
顔も見たくありませんでした
大学を機に家を出た僕は
東京で
3年
酒屋に努めます
いやいや家業につれまをされたときには
安い御林が売れる時代は終わっていました
取引先の件数も販売量
人になっていました
時代は
量より質
会社の方向性を変えなければ
潰れてしまう
当時はよく父親と大喧嘩をしました
会社に戻って
10年が経ちました
父親が僕に経営を渡すと決めました
僕は
いよいよ俺の時代だ
必ずに対してやるぞ
と
意気揚々とスタートしました
でも
ここからが
本当の
苦難の始まりでした
見た目と違い
会社の内情は倒産寸前
何をどうしていいのか
まったくわからない
苦しくて苦しくて
その場から逃げ出したい
家にも会社にも戻らず
よく海を眺めにばかりがきました
そんな時でした
会社をやるのか辞めるのか
心の整理がつかない中
蔵の2階を片付け始めました
そこで偶然
一つのメモを見つけます
押入れに積まれた書類の山の中
鉛筆で書かれた手のひらに乗るほどの小さい紙
100年の時を超え
蔵の中で眠っていた虫食いだらけのメモ
今僕に合わんとばかりタイミングデー
僕の目の前に現れました
書かれていたのは
おじいさんのレシピ
なんて贅沢な配合だおじいさんはこんな無茶苦茶
恋3 d を作っていたんだ
どんな味でどんな思いで
みりんを作っていたんだおじいさんの3人が味わってみたい
正直
僕は看板を下そうと考えていました
でも
このレシピを手にした今
おじいさんの思いのこもった
i 桜の看板だけは
何が何でも俺が守ってやると思いました
ん
自分の原点は自分で守る
おじいさんのレシピを
復刻させること
決意しました
とはいえ
昔作りの
midi を戻すことは並大抵ではありません
設備や原料のことも心配でしたが
会社の方向性を変えなければ
それ以上に作り手の思いを伝えなければと思いました
なけなしの資金デー
昔ながら手搾り器を手に入れました
地元農家には
減量前を直接仕入れないと交渉しました
見たーー3人の
一番の肝である
本格焼酎を確保しました
そして
唯一会社で0
昔作りの経験がある
職人さんの
記憶と勘だけを耐えうる
おじいさんのみりんを
作り始めました
まず
米を蒸し
講師を育て
みりんの本仕込みよし
半年間じっくり熟成させ絞る
そして出来上がったみん
そっと縁に含んでみました
みりんってこんなに甘いんだ
砂糖も入っていないのに米だけでこんなに甘いんがぁ
米だけの奄美に鳥肌が立ちました
まさにこれぞおじいさんの3人だ
100年前何もなかった時代に
シンプル丁寧
作られていた
おじいさんのミリーを
今こそ
俺が
伝えていかなければと思いました
じっくりと時間をかける事がこんなに楽しく
面白いことだと人生で初めて味わうことができました
こうして
ようやく自信を持って売りたい
右を作ることができましたが
安い御林に慣れた人には
まったく
受け入れられませんでした
やがて
売れ残ったミリーは
熟成が進み
色が黒
ふろっ
業界では未だかつてない色に変わっていました
こんな黒いミニ誰が買うんだ
と皆に笑われ
でも
自分の手で
作った3人だったので
試しに舐めてみました
すると
むちゃくちゃ枚山
全然違う奄美
味も濃いしうまいし
むちゃくちゃ美味しいじゃん
3年経つとこんなに違うんだ
タンクの中で
熟成されて
生きた講師が働き
見事なまでの熟成感
こうして
奇跡が重なり
3年ミリー
俺の3人は生まれました
俺の身には
本当の3カー3人の味を僕に教えてくれました
でもそれだけじゃないんです
会社のあり方
商売の方向性
誰に何をどう伝えればいいのか
働くことへのいい
仕事への誇り
今まで考えても考えてもまったくわからなかった答えがへ
この俺のビリーは
僕に教えてくれました
情熱等
やる気が沸々と込み上げ
これで行くんだ
と
確固たる決意が出来上がりました
俺のみりん
3年3人に出会って10年が経ちました
僕は今53歳
おじいさんのように
酒好きは
全く変わりませんが
どうやら
俺のというものを見つけたことによって
まだまだ死にそうにはありません
だって
まだまだたくさんやりたいことがあるし
ワクワク感が止まらないからです
誰にも俺のというものがあるとは限りません
たとえあったとしても僕のように
時間がかかることでしょう
みんなにおじいさんのレシピがあるわけでもありません
でも
うまくいかなかったときには
考えてみてください
自分の原点
思いを馳せてみてください
そして自分に
焦るなよ
ゆっくりと
時間とテーマ
かけてごらん大丈夫だ
と
行ってみてください
じっくりと
時間かけた先
it
楽しく
味わい深い
俺のという人生が待っています
ありがとうございましたん
[音楽]